since the World Series starts tomorrow
night I thought would bring out our own
sports handicapping animal showing
precision from this animal
please welcome chickpea the World Series
predicting chicken
[Applause]
all right well as you can see we've
given chickpea a Mets and Royals helmet
both are filled with chicken feed that
chickpea can choose from
whichever helmet she eats out of that's
the team she thinks will win the World
Series and again chillin she says meds
on the road to break the season 370 runs
sports herd in a major league baseball
but the Royals were a stellar 51 and 30
mm she's saying the Mets have had great
pitching so far in the playoffs but the
Royals defense has been amazing this
postseason
very realistic puppetry the Mets mascot
she says is really dumb
the Royals mascot Slugger is a lion
which finds barn animals
[Applause]
let's snap out of it chickpeas stop
watching scary stuff just stop it
stop having hey move with your feet now
tell us what is your prediction
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why did we hear the sound of the
hatching long before the hatching cute
of a gesture from chickpea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey the world series we're doing chicken
everybody my check wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]